reindeers are real Christmas Israel I
swear to God if I could not pass at
least one child at this time I just
can't do anything right I love Christmas
but I'm also an adult so I don't think
I'll have any trouble not smiling also
my competition is Clark
so I will not smile because I've been a
bad boy things that would make me smile
and my cell phone bill paying my rent
Christmas sucks let's go see the title
of this movie and already know I'm not
gonna do good why are you smiling like
that I just like to smile smiling's my
favorite
this is actually my favorite Christmas
movie okay people tomorrow morning 10
a.m. Santa's comin I do it this would
make anybody smile though this is not
fair boom I did it I completed the first
challenge this is my time got out all my
little giggles I'm about so you know
straight G mode
you can't smile would you like to sit on
two is that okay
am I allowed it's surprisingly really
hard not to smile when you're looking at
Santa Claus oh you did it I'm good how
are you mrs. Claus had some some medical
work done so she can't really stand that
well you could take my job I don't know
what's a day look how about that this is
the secret to marriage okay say yes and
do what you want don't that work out for
you
she found the coat on so now Santa has a
new routine he says he's working on it
would you like to sit on Santa's lap
yeah sure okay don't put all your weight
down internet troll an IRL Santa is like
really chatty I smiled because it's just
like really awkward and creepy was weird
this better not be no BuzzFeed animals
kitten [ __ ] I don't know why I
always sign up for this stuff there
might be in like an animal surprise
there as a animal how do humans but then
you lose the challenge okay I'm thinking
not happy thoughts I'm not gonna smile I
am in a cage oh my gosh
[Laughter]
those are real-life reindeer I didn't
know that reindeer were real do they
have names a reindeer Brooklyn its Holly
Jolly shimmy hi Prancer okay I'm gonna
say I failed this challenge because I
just want to like revel in this
beautiful moment it's a Christmas
miracle
it's the most wonderful time of the year
the spirit of Christmas is alive in
Brooklyn happy holidays remember to
smile fake your parents and dance and
prance and jingle on your merry way
[Music]